[Music]
all the west virginia news our majestic
and our brand their son with faith in
glory like the prince emmanuel's land is
it any wonder then that my heart could
rapture bill as i stand once more with
the loved ones on the west agenda here
[Music]
among the western
[Music]
all the west virginia hills i must bid
you now will do in my home beyond the
mountains i shall ever dream of you
in the evening time of life if my father
only will i
virginia here
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
hey ray good to see you
you want to show me what you guys built
next door show me the house next door
take me over there
show me this
very nice you got a new car too
you got this too
yeah
yeah
nice who's staying here
stay there right
larry is this the car you got
is this the car you got no you got that
turtle right there oh the the truck
backs up
i'm sorry i said that the truck my fault
it messed up on oh okay i gotta get it
back all right well we can help you with
that
i hope you do
i've become like your new uh lifeline
yeah i understand that's all right
that's all right
how have you guys been
you look great when
we didn't meet doctor daddy
we're doing okay you survived winter
spring's coming yeah i know
what are you showing me i can't i can't
wait what's over there
you want to take me hey hey
hey kenneth how's that mark good
so you're staying next door yeah how
about that one
that's great
that's nice so what have you guys done
with some of the money i gave you you
got a new a new roof
not your bro
the roof looks great
put your inside around the house you got
siding
yeah i don't even i don't even recognize
the house
new kitchen cabinets
and a car
excellent
the truck yes i mean that's great now
are you corn down on the floor i'm sorry
you fall down on the floor oh i see yeah
excellent
yeah hey lorraine how are you
[ __ ] on my tongue i know she doesn't
talk much
timmy talks
thank you i'm doing damn me
how are you timmy
you guys all look healthy
what's going on you guys had dinner yet
uh have you had dinner yet no what are
you guys gonna do for dinner tonight i
have no idea what do you guys normally
do
typically like when i've been here but
in the past i see ray grab
a loaf of bread and some some like
sliced meat and he makes a little
sandwich
yeah bologna or whatever something like
that
you know
all that anybody cook here
no nobody cut their candy bars
yeah
i do a lot of cooking what kind of what
kind of stuff will you make for these
guys i made many times and
she get it out not fixing for him
investigating and stuff like that
she liked my cooking i guess yeah
i can't get on my leg long enough
her legs make a lot of trouble your leg
yeah how's ray's knee
well he's not walking around
yeah you seem strong
oh right here you're taking another piss
ray doesn't use the bathroom
yes i see that i see that
and everybody drive by here they open up
yeah yeah right yeah because they know
here
right your knee is better
yeah the siding looks beautiful
yeah
what are you doing in the back
you're in the in the creek show me okay
take me to your beautiful creek
take me to your creek
show me the creek
huh
yeah that's the sighting the extra extra
siding
who stays next door
what's going on next door
what at large place
that's where i live
you live next door
yeah i don't know who lives where
so you stay there
[Music]
kenneth is in the new trailer
[Music]
and lorraine and
lorraine and betty timmy and
ray stay here yeah
show me ray's bedroom
can you show me ray's bedroom
he wants a red bedroom it's right there
in the living room ray show me your
bedroom
what
so the money has helped you a lot
it's improved your quality of your life
a bit
the the money has improved your lives a
bit
that's great
it's nice that we could help out
yeah
a lot of people donated a lot of money
show me ray i hear my porn
oh you have another bedroom here can i
peek in
i'm being nosy
so that's where you sleep buddy
this is your room
where do you stay
there oh you sleep on the sofa
yeah
that's where you sleep all year long
so who sleeps there
who who sleeps in this room
teaming what were you sure oh they share
a bed
oh okay
who's that dog
it's my dog
who's that what's his name
what's her name his name's wolfie wolfie
yeah and how many dogs do you have
exactly right there
sassy how's jason
how's jason he's still in jail
yeah what does he get now do we know
tell jason i'd love to do an interview
with him
i i would love to do an interview with
jason if he if he's willing
jason i'm fascinated with brother you
did say that you'd be alone
but i couldn't bear to see you in such
streets
it's okay
yeah you're walking around just fine
you were hurting last time i was here
tell me about your kitchen you guys ever
cook
show me your kitchen do you guys ever
cook
who cooks who cooks here well sometimes
i cook in the morning
cooking
and there's my kitchen cabinet
but kenneth cooks for you guys kenneth
cooks for you guys sometimes yeah
and i bought that used deep freezer
money
oh your stock your fridge is well
stocked
nice
we're getting the whole tour here
that's a heater
yeah yeah
hey you ever take a bath i saw you in
the bath once i came in and you were
taking a bath
including
what's back there show me
oh the laundry room
time to take the garbage out right
that's fine
hey
so everyone health everyone's health is
okay
everyone's health is okay oh yeah you
guys look healthy you look good in the
doctor and stuff like that
lorraine's heart timmy's timmy had a
heart issue too right
right i didn't hit it
or amazon i didn't know
give me a problem ready
you guys stay healthy
you gotta you gotta stay healthy because
you're the you're the one that keeps
this whole cookie yeah clan together
like nothing more than that
i'm i'm worried about you more than
anybody even though you look great
you look fine
up
how long has it been here
since october
now halloween night
they brought in
because you were living in beaver for a
while right
you got a new fever
yeah
i tried to fix that there was anything
i got insulation
nice
money
you ran out of
money now
all right well
these videos tend to
get you guys some help we got a nice
bedroom in there look at that yeah you
got the nicest room in the in the hole
yeah you're cleaner than the rest of
your family oh yeah
what was it what was the rest of the
family like
so i i know ray and timmy lorraine betty
larry
but the rest of the gang i don't really
know so much tell me tell me about the
rest of the family i don't know i don't
know how you secrets my friends
no but what about growing up as a kid
who else was there
i don't know
we've done a lot of that when
yeah what kind of stuff would you guys
get into i'll work in the garden get out
of that playing mud
make my cake drop that
everybody yeah
the ones that have the biggest
impairment would be like rey and
lorraine right yeah
everyone else was a little better off
yeah
no one else was like ray or lorraine
and then timmy came and joined the gang
yeah what what what do you think the
the problem that ray has and ray and
lorraine and maybe even timmy what do
you think it is is it environmental or
is it genetic
yeah but like you know even the eyes
like your eyes are a little bit off you
know yeah i'm not quite yeah and larry
has you know everyone seems to have that
in the family yeah do you think that was
genetic or do you think it was uh
environmental from coal mining i don't
know it might be
yeah
what are you showing me ray
yeah
yeah well you want a cake
ray wants a treat
there you drink
oh yeah
i can't fix it up right now all right
well maybe maybe this video will
generate a little more attention you
guys can fix up this uh
the interior of your uh
your trailer yeah the exterior looks
nice
the exterior looks nice oh yeah and they
did a nice job fixing up their place oh
yeah i'm gonna have to fit
done everything
you know
it's nice here on this street
[Applause]
road
it used to be a dirt road right
yeah i need to be the dirt road
and there used to be how many 15 14
okay
15 yep all here yeah over here
raise it up
your parents were busy
got four or five room houses over
we raised that door
there's four or five rooms over there
yeah it was in that house oh there was a
house yeah it was a house over there
fell down
i don't know i moved out like the dirty
though i moved out when i got it i was
18. you moved out when you were 18. you
finished high school
yeah
what and what kind of work have you done
how are you going to work bark at night
come to club cutting timbers and stuff
like that
you ever think about leaving west
virginia
i live with me
i didn't even know crime
virginia kentucky
oh you see you've been around i've been
around these guys have never left the
state
these guys have never i bet you these
guys have never left raleigh county
no
way to go visit somebody in that
rebellion
ray you like it here
you're happy
i gave you a bunch of coat
i got you a bunch of coats
i thought was those
he's all drunk up right now what's your
favorite memory as a kid kenneth
what what's your favorite memory as a
kid right ray
ray used to be much rowdier though yeah
i remember the first time i met ray when
freddie was around
yeah and and ray was so out of control
yeah i i walked up to this
i think you were the one that helped me
get them to uh allow me to photograph
them
it was you there
yeah down on the side you you were the
one that helped me yeah because i think
somebody had just passed away
and uh larry was in the house in the
trailer across the street and he said we
just we're mourning somebody who passed
away yeah and they didn't want me to
bother anybody and i said okay i gotta
respect that right but then i came up
with the
the idea that maybe taking an 8x10
polaroid which is what i was doing at
the time an instant photo that you could
put in the casket with the person that
passed away
and i guess everyone liked that idea and
you helped me take a photo of you and
then i took a photo of ray and i took a
photo of timmy and then eventually oh no
freddy and then eventually which we
tried to get ray to cooperate and every
time i'd
i had the photo the camera set up on a
tripod and i asked ray to stand for the
camera he would stand like right next to
it like this
and he uh
and as soon as i asked him to step back
he got upset and he ran off his pants
would fall around his ankles because
they didn't have a belt and he'd go
kicking a garbage can you remember
raised to do this yeah yeah he'd kick a
garbage or a metal garbage can and just
like scream in the corner yeah and this
happened over and over and over
and then eventually he got ready to
stand for a photo
with timmy and uh and freddy all right
yeah i'll give you
but he's calmed down look at right look
at ray he's mellow now
yeah you sway a little bit
yeah
which one which one is it your left knee
or your right knee where'd you want to
hurt you
you're walking fine
you seem okay you get out here walk
everywhere you take up without the road
you can't go get him he goes for a walk
yeah he walks the dogs or anything oh
yeah yeah
yeah you keep your trailers nice nice
and clean
yeah
hey
not like the rest of your family are you
horrified by the dirt over there it's a
mess over there yeah yeah
is that is that how the parents were
when they grow up
was it a messy house
yeah
yeah the apple don't doesn't fall too
far from the tree
yeah yeah
that's nice you've you've kept it
together and you were married once right
yeah i was married once before mm-hmm
you're saying i'm lord you're single now
yeah we ran into you at walmart so i saw
your is your daughter
that was your step daughter how are you
doing yeah
she's living with your grandmother's
grandpa right now
i won't go down to sleep when i get done
with ain't working
yeah i work a lot
you know a good truck so this is the
truck you guys bought with some of the
money
just bought my brother yeah
okay i gave ten thousand
i was in my own pocket oh you paid for
this i'll pay for it
i played 405 oh hold on what happened
you got an accident here
he hit a deer you hit a deer
yeah larry did hurry again
yeah i see
how's the deer
how's the deer i don't hate that
youtuber
yeah
is your firewood this is how you heat
the house
yeah i got 10 grand for this
you pay 10 grand 10 grand 10 grand
i got on payment 400 500 405 dollars
every month
what do you see what are you pointing to
rick ray
what do you think
oh you're talking about a tree you feel
oh a tree though
it didn't hurt anything
hey it makes a route
oh it fell on the house yeah you fell
around the destroyer oh wow
when did this happen
i don't know i wouldn't even around then
they take a big
a pine tree feeling
yeah
yeah i see
i see
yeah yeah i cut those trees out of there
right
i get a journey
right you don't like the belt i got you
you don't like the belt
you don't wear a belt he don't worry
bill
he got a bunch of bailey in there is
that right yeah
people
getting a bottom of bell he don't worry
people don't change yeah
yeah right
yeah
yeah
what's your favorite season ray you like
you like summer you like winter
you're right it's summer winter right
you like the snow
he won't get up when it's nothing yeah i
don't blame him it's cold here get out
of here
you won't see me in the winter either i
grew up in that
i hate to
i need to get out there working
that's not for me is that pogo right
yeah you buy a vehicle
can ray ride a bicycle hey youtube now
yeah when you're growing up now
i don't know
i'd love to see ray on a bicycle right
get on that bicycle
so mark you get on about to get down the
road hey he won't take a picture of me
can you ride a bike hey
yeah i'll hold it
here i'll hold your cape
go get out
right
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
what was it like growing up here what
was it like growing up here as kids it's
okay yeah it's really nice
what kind of things would you guys do
what kind of things would you guys do as
kids
photographs
15 kids
15 kids yeah
there was a house across the street yeah
it was a house right there where your
trailer is now where your trailer is
did you have this one then
did you have
if you had more money what would you
continue to do and what what am i we're
going to finish you're picking this
house up yeah we are you've done a nice
job so far yeah
what takes so much
people charging you a lot yeah i know
house house improvements aren't cheap
yeah i know
you tell me what money
i will get
picked up over there
yeah we'll help you out
timmy what are you doing what are you
doing are you drawing
right he's writing
show me what you're right
right right in there
he probably carried him out when he
writes in him no
he probably pulled him out
he turns him out when he get home
that's what he wrote
give me one
timmy
you can spell dog
i think timmy is much smarter than
he appears he graduated high school you
graduated high school timmy yeah yeah
yeah
i ain't great
who's the i know timmy's uh a nephew
yeah who's the youngest of the 15 kids
she comes to visit you sometimes yeah
yeah
who's the oldest
dad
lorraine is the oldest yeah no no
you guys you guys see each other still
you guys all see each other
you're the one who drives yeah yeah oh
the one here god
you and you and betty are the are the no
i've got to go no but but you you two
are the ones who keep everything
together pay the bills do whatever you
need to do right i take betty's store
take and pay their bills and all that
yeah
you know i'm right here all the time
yeah you know
then i got my older secretary she called
want me to take her start
you know all that and i tell your store
to walmart you know
you know
i've been pretty busy you know yeah you
guys stay busy
tell me something about lorraine i know
very little about lorraine she's the
mystery
member of the family she doesn't require
she won't say nobody
she wouldn't talk to the doctor
yeah lorraine you look healthy
you guys ready for summer
you ready for summer i'm ready for
summer mark
all right nice seeing you guys again
nice i'll see you again sometime this
summer i'm sure i'll be back
we'll come visit you
all right
thanks everybody
ray
we'll see you later
come on bye
bye
thanks everybody okay
all right bye bye
you